What's up guys!
We are Pongfinity.
We have tried giant ping pong, but today we will do mini ping pong.
Let's start with half a table.
This looks really weird.
Sorry!
What was that?
It wasn't on the table.
I could have easily made it...
I actually got it in!
Now we have an even smaller table.
Chop block.
Was it around the net?
Yes.
That was around the net.
Okay, we are taking this one step further with a mini racket and mini ball.
That was the world's smallest around the net.
Perhaps!
Let's see.
Zero - zero.
Yes! I got one point!
I gave him the one point.
Thank you!
I'm coming back!
Net serve.
I'll put some underspin.
So lucky!
Easy!
Good match!
The fastest table tennis set ever.
Thanks for watching guys! Hope you enjoyed this episode.
Remember to subscribe here
And check out our previous videos there.
Until next time!